I'll mention one other project too.
Jen Lowe is an artist and
data visualizer based in New York, and she has this project called One,
I think it's called One Human Heartbeat and she has a device I forget if it's,
you know, I don't remember if it's something she puts on her wrist or
something, but it's a device that like measures, tracks your heartbeat.
And if you go to this website,
you can see your heartbeat visualized with a 24 hour delay.
So, like every night, she plugs the device in and it syncs up, and
it cuts the data off, and all you see is just this, like, pulsing, but it's like
an ac, it's, it's a really intense, because it's an actual representation of her
actual heartbeat, and so if it's going faster or going slower.
And I think it's such a beautiful visualization.
It's more like conceptual art than, you know,
it does, doesn't give you this history, like this histogram over time.
It just gives you here's my heart beating.
This is like a real person that you're seeing translated on to your screen